Hey! Conan 360 Live.
I am John Kourounis of Warner Brothers'
Studio Tour Hollywood.
I'm currently standing
in the Warner Brothers'
archive museum and I
cannot wait to show you
around some of my
absolute favorite things.
Let's check it out.
Here we have Wonder Woman.
Now this is as you would've seen her
in Batman Vs. Superman, where
we were really introduced
to Gal Gadot's performance
of Wonder Woman.
And we have her original costume here.
Absolutely love it.
If you guys check it out,
they were designed by Michael Wilkinson,
directed by Zack Snyder,
what a wonderful, wonderful movie.
Great character, great performance.
Now right next to that, just in case,
you know, we ever have
another super attack,
we have the kryptonite staff
that Batman also uses
in Batman Vs. Superman.
Speaking of Batman, take a look.
Now he's got a few different
costumes that we actually see
in Batman Vs. Superman,
and this is one of my
personal favorite ones.
You can see that it's really
got some wear and tear
because he is Batman,
he's been Batman for a really long time.
How cool are these things?
Now we're back in the
Suicide Squad section
of our archive, and you can see
some of the Joker's henchmen.
I actually tried to borrow
this for Valentine's Day.
Not only did the studio not let me do it,
but my girlfriend was
like, absolutely not.
We have another one of
the Joker's henchmen.
He's got an eye for crime.
Moving right along.
You can see the Joker himself, right here.
Played by Jared Leto,
and his Joker was really
kind of inspired by like
the rich kids of Instagram.
He's a very indulgent Joker,
and believe it or not,
not many people know this,
this is the exact tuxedo Jared Leto
also wore to the Academy Awards.
All authentic costumes and props.
All the way on the wall over here,
we have part of the Wayne mausoleum,
and also little Wayne, right here.
We also have one of my favorite things,
all original, first
edition, number one comics
straight out of the DC comic vault,
never been on display before.
We have Green Lantern,
we have Flash,
the very first Batman comic.
We have Superman,
we have Wonder Woman,
we have Cyborg.
C'mon guys, Cyborg. Get excited.
New Teen Titans, that's what that is.
We also have Aquaman,
we have the Lois, Clark, and Perry suits
from the Daily Planet.
And, as you can clearly see,
Superman himself.
3D printed suit, you have to put
this thing on like a wetsuit.
He's also got the
language of Krypton across
the S and on his shoulders.
And little known fact, they
actually got the molding
from tour guides for the suit right here.
That's not true. At all.
Listen, that's gonna do
it for me, John Kourounis.
Come see all of these things for yourself
at Warner Brothers' Studio Tour Hollywood,
because these are just a few
of the amazing things on this tour.
So book your tickets
today, wbstudiotour.com,
and we will see you soon.